we've got savage Kaelin Blake's not my
favorite person
we have adorable Dylan and hurricane
Blake so here is to second chances
this is your bachelor in paradise recap
grab your glasses it's time for roses
and roses eh
hi you guys i'm lauren zima look at this
palm tree Oh everybody the Bachelorette
was over for just a moment now we're
back in paradise don't you know I am so
happy to be back with you guys we've
done a little bit of a changeup for the
set with this polisher because it has
paradise you get it
we're not subtle I'm also wearing a
dress that literally has a banana leaf
print on it so themes and the theme of
this season of paradise already seems to
be going hard yes episode one was
unbelievable what did you guys think we
are going at 90 miles an hour on this
season of paradise let's get to it
[Applause]
[Music]
so we get some intro packages they
always do
the packages in the beginning whatever
it was cute because you know we're gonna
catch up with some people
I am Blake from bet the season of the
best ribs here's the thing their words
not mine Chris Harrison and ABC exec
reveals both told me that Blake will
take the title from Dean and be the
biggest F Boyd in Paradise history so
now it's gonna be a little bit like
watching Jed on Hannah season isn't it
not what I'm saying Blake equals Jed
they didn't do the same things but we're
going to observe Blake with that same
awareness you know we've seen the
trailers we know things go downhill for
Blake so now I'm kind of analyzing
everything he's saying you know such as
him saying that he has learned a lot
about what he wants in a woman I learned
a lot about myself and kind of what I'm
looking for I wonder what I'm looking
for in a relationship maybe from all the
exploring and recon work all the
research of different music festivals
field work really buy a real scientist
my name is cam and you may have
remembered me from Hanabi season of The
Bachelorette we're gonna get cam cam
wrapped and you guys I didn't peek on
the bead if you don't know who
I'm keeping it ABC because she over
handle eyes and manipulate cam has
gotten fit he's looking good I never
thought cam was a fundamentally bad guy
he's just kind of awkward so what do you
think will cam be kind of like an Evan
Bass and like get a second chance in
paradise always these getting chances
let me know in the comments below going
to paradise paradise then we get to my
babe Demi and she's with her baby Hannah
I love what the babes are together and
we acknowledge right from the beginning
that Demi was in a relationship with a
woman I have kind of been seeing someone
like of course plot twist it happens to
be a woman that she's not sure where
it's going to go and that she wants to
head to Paradise to explore and learn
more about herself I just like who I
like it doesn't matter who or what you
are like it's the person you're a fluid
person you're not just this one thing I
really like the way that this was
handled we knew from the promos that
this season was going to tackle the
franchise's first ever queer
relationship with Demi and bringing in
this woman at some point that she dated
in the past a non franchise alum by the
way though that's not a first for the
franchise they have some that before
aren't made quite large Shh you're
you're doing too much research now
mentally bottom line I appreciated that
demisexuality wasn't treated as some
kind of big reveal we just got it right
off the top in the episode it's normal
it's who she is we love her tell me what
you guys thought of it because this is a
big moment for the franchise and we're
glad it's happening cheers to it by the
way I have my self-care wineglass today
because this is a lot gotta buckle up no
weights paradise is the ocean we gotta
put our life vest on get the boat stop
it Lauren okay all right we hit the
beach and people are getting there and
Blake got there and drink every time
Blake says he's ready for love I'm
excited to just give love another shot I
hope I do follow I am ready to find
somebody and hopefully paradise has that
you've been in the bachelor world for
about a year now yes
Blake arrives and Chris Harrison asks
him about whether he's been commingling
with other people from bachelor nation I
know you all talk and mess you commingle
and Blake either didn't understand
Chris's implication with commingling or
just chose to Blake breeze right past it
and treat it as if Chris was asking him
if he subtracted two people there's a
few yeah there's a few girls that I you
know I think I would get along really
well with him he was asking about the
hookups babe okay he knows what's up
swollen man you ready to go yeah I'm
very much excited ease y'all paradise
dawg yeah Kevin from Hannah season is
here and I'm only acknowledging Kevin
because of something he said Kevin said
not many women can fall off rompers and
you are pulling this off most women
can't pull off robbers don't have a
proper like you're not doing yourself
any favors for me here keV maybe most
men can't pull off
- you know Tyler see ok rude I love a
Robert do you guys love him ever they
make me feel comfortable and confident
ok bye well ones arrived willed is here
and he is so excited about the prospect
of Hannah G that he has dyed his hair
blonde okay now we're getting dangerous
everybody so please drink responsibly
drink for every hilarious observation by
Chris Harrison we're gonna need a tan oh
for sure
it's a leopard print shirt you got there
fantastic drink every time cam says
something c4 cringe-worthy are you
wearing colored contacts no I'm calling
it kind of early but I think she's gonna
make an amazing mom let's fast forward
and say we have a daughter yeah and then
all is right in these rocky waters John
Paul Jones arrived I would expect
nothing less from you [ __ ] oh he's in
a speedo God he's the best you guys he
literally makes me laugh out loud he's
such a joy
he's this amazing combination of on the
one hand being totally in it he's really
committed to being here in paradise on
the other hand he seems to always be
thinking what's good I'm ready to surf
you know whatever waves hit paradise
Shaka brah let's go Chris Harrison's
been real man you know it's a
self-awareness and I'm really interested
to see who john paul jones could end up
with who do you ship JPJ with by the way
I love that he's now Juan Pablo Jones is
there Juan Paul Jones here drink every
time JPJ says yeah but if something
bothers me you're gonna know it bothers
and I'm a straight shot look I call it
how it is sometimes that comes off like
seeming like [ __ ] yeah like yeah like
paradise we're going hard but please
drink responsibly the chicken nugget if
you can there's no drama everybody seems
to be really friendly and getting along
so so far so good
kaylynn arrives and Kailyn comes in hat
and ride hot I mean savage yeah I've
seen I've saw someone just tell me do I
need to know anything heading into
paradise inland just tells Chris
Harrison the whole tawdry story you know
Blake's not my favorite person
yeah say you were seeing Blake and it
didn't end well
it did not interesting Blake talking and
then hooking up at the stagecoach music
festival earlier this year and of her
finding out that Blake hooked up with
Christina Schulman literally the night
before and drink every time Kaylin is
savage Blake's not my favorite person
I wish I could have told her hey he's
not a good guy he puts on her very like
suave sweet guy persona so that's gonna
be the mage drama with Blake you know he
spent the night together and we wake up
I'm in his bed and he's like damning
Hannah G and later in the episode we
find out from Kailyn that Blake was
allegedly in bed with her the morning
after DMing Hannah G am talking about
how hot he thought Taoiseach was and he
just hooked up with Kristina the night
before what's going on at stagecoach I
don't wanna go to stagecoach it seems so
scary venture musics supposed to be a
safe place America anyway
I gotta go so Blake by the way seemed
truly shocked that Kaelin arrived like
Blake this is a TV show and your issues
out there on social media the producers
are gonna produce the TV show are you
really surprised why am I talking like
this I don't know I became a wise old
southern lady put Blake in his little
place bad which does not kill us makes
us stronger in that little place is a
Bennett stagecoach oh my God why is it
the same bed oh jesus oh Jesus you guys
come join me up in the palapa real quick
so the first group has arrived and Chris
is gonna officially welcome everybody
and he says Jellyman gentlemen find your
palapa gentleman gentleman is did he
slip and say that because there aren't
any real gentlemen here gentlemen
no Dalits here hotshots there are sure
things aren't they like it's a date card
and that's really now Kaylin I was
surprised she's not telling the other
people about this past with Blake who
wants some no one to know
he played me and that hurt me just
holding it all in and I'm like girl why
not I feel like I might die if he
treated you poorly you don't owe him
anything
do you guys think Galen should just tell
everyone about the severed Blake I don't
see myself with anyone else here in
paradise besides Hannah um but while
Cailin is not falling for anyone yet in
paradise
I am I'm falling for Dylan you guys
Dylan is real remember I thought he was
a ghost well he is a real boy and he's
here now and in fact he's a man I love
everything about the way Dylan is
talking about Hannah she drink every
time he's totally adorable about Hannah
I couldn't stop smiling because I like
Hannah a lot there's no other girl I
want to talk to you especially with
Hannah who's just unbelievable walk like
I'm so nervous
the whole time I'm like holy crap well I
think with Hannah specifically she just
makes me feel like super nervous I mean
I just think she's totally out of my
league to be honest now while we also
thought that Blake was at the Hannah
late we definitely hit it off today and
Hannah I thought Blake was into her too
and this was very much a rumored hot
couple that could come out of paradise
but he ain't gets a date card and takes
out a shot sure really it's gonna be
okay why do you think Blake took out
tisha I think Blake was just really
feeling himself and feeling like he
could feel out all his options that's
what paradise is for but on the other is
that foreshadowing again and analyzing
everything Blake says he does the cheers
to second chances here is two second
chances yikes will he get one and then
he says that line about you know
appreciating the right person cuz you've
been with the wrong person if you can
love the wrong person that much
how much will you be able to love the
right person is he being genuine or
genuinely being a player you tell me
what do you think let me know in the
comments below but now the episode is
coming to a close and we are freaking
off everybody we are off we are going
off Kalin is crying and Blake and tisha
are kissing and Demi and Derick are
making out in the hot tub and had some
fun and Sarah tonight and Dylan and
Hannah are connecting that is what I'm
like so excited about is I think we get
along so well already quite literally is
the best night of my life with Hannah
hey so cute by the way I interviewed him
a shameless plug itself a TT online
comedy is so sweet talking about Hannah
you guys I love it do you love Dylan let
me know the comments below if you don't
what are you doing
ABCD always be clapping for Dylan
Christina and then Christina arrives and
Blake's face and it's like dude are you
new here this is a reality show why is
he so shocked
Oh Blake is so flabbergasted by
Kristina's arrival that as he's trying
to explain this story of what's been
going on with him and this women he says
sex instead of six months I'm you
Christine were hanging out maybe like
six or seven months ago six or seven
months ago I got and then he's like me
and Christine are good totally great
we're friends we are excellent
everything's fine we ended amicably
everything's good we are just dear
friends I was happy to see her I was so
happy to see her appreciate her and she
appreciates me at that we decided stay
friends and we have them know we're
totally it turns me everything is
wonderful like we couldn't be I feel
like honestly we talked a life is still
there for each other we are borderline
like married but not right like we're
not sexually attracted to each other be
honest we've been very open with each
other
it's like she's my wife and it's like I
would do anything
and you're immune like we could have to
go to me front we could cope parents we
get divorce and it'll be everything we
could be are like so completely in tune
with each other but it gained it very
like mutually and it's good at the end
here Christina gets a date card I was
thinking of like taking you and she
takes that why did you do that I was
confused you guys what do you think
why is Christina using slash wasting her
date card on blatant so today I'm going
to make blades like this she said she
has something up her sleeve is she
seriously taking Blake on a date just to
mess with him to get revenge if she is
what do you think worth it let me know
the comments below all in all everybody
loved this season premiere of bachelor
in paradise and we are doing two
episodes of roses and Rosie every week
yes on Tuesday morning you'll get the
Monday night show recap on Wednesday
morning you'll get the Tuesday night's
show recap I love you guys so much thank
you
unendingly for being here and because we
didn't get him for the roses and roses a
finale JC I just need you to come show
everybody what you're wearing I put on
my banana leaf print JC is in stunning
bachelor Beach fashion you are ready for
paradise thank you
oh my god guys this is a glow up that
shows up love you guys
[Music]